ewen o'toole bonsoir bonsoir d'abord
félicitations merci beaucoup
est ce que quand vous êtes entré dans
cette course là vous êtes dit bon je
vais y aller parce que la dernière fois
je suis arrivé 3e je vais donner tout ce
que j'ai mais j'ai peut-être pas
beaucoup de chances contre d'autres où
dès le début vous pensiez que c'était
possible
oui j'étais le long de dahouët sûr mais
j'ai une équipe extraordinaire à des
notions à à l'autre et on a travaillé
plus fort et je suis très fier de mon
équipe particulièrement sur le terrain
au québec et grâce à mon équipe
gt1 j'ai gagné et je suis prêt pour
gagner la prochaine élection aussi bon
mais justement la prochaine élection est
ce que vous souhaitez comme chef
conservateur faire tomber le
gouvernement trudeau le plus tôt
possible
donc dès le discours du trône un homme
ma priorité et le bien-être des
canadiens canadien et le bien-être des
pme à endroit avoir un plan pour la
relance économique et je suis en
politique pour ça mais c'est important
d'être prêt aussi parce que le
gouvernement trudeau a joué les jeux
politiques avec le discours du trône et
on va être prêt pour l'élection mais je
vais continuer sur le bien-être des
canadiens d'accord dont vous allez pas
le faire tomber
s'il tombe ça sera pas à cause de vous
non c'est à cause de monsieur trudeau
bien sûr il a il a prodigué à le
parlement pour pau après les questions
sur les scandales oui attendant une
pandémie
on a une difficile plus de 300 milliards
de dollars un niveau de chômage très
élevé il y à beaucoup de défis en vain
avant nous maintenant et c'est important
d'avoir un plan cuir
un homme d'action j'ai un plan on a une
équipe extraordinaire et nous sommes
prêts d'être le gouvernement dont on
peut voir les prochaines années c'est ça
mais votre premier choix pour qu'on soit
qu'un pour les gens qui nous écoutent
votre premier choix c'est de ne pas
faire tomber le gouvernement trudeau cet
automne donc dans quelques semaines et
de plutôt attendre au printemps par
exemple
oui là l'action serait là choix de
premier ministre ou d'eau je suis ici
comme chef de l'opposition pour le
bien-être des canadiens et je suis prêt
de travailler procès ensemble et on va
annoncer les politiques au pôle économie
pour les pme et c'est ma priorité
l'économie le déficit talent d'économie
la taille du déficit est ce que ça vous
inquiète
est-ce que vous pensez que le grenat
trudeau a trop dépensé pendant la
pandémie est est ce que vous allez
proposer un remède de cheval pour
réduire le déficit est ce que vous allez
devoir demander aux canadiens de serrer
la ceinture des compressions et c'est le
gouvernement trudeau était l'un est né
avec leur réponse après le premier
procès clairement avec la frontière on
ferait payer
et maintenant on doit voir poindre
réduire les programmes d'urgence comme
les prestations canadiennes d'urgence et
les autres mais dans une manière juste
et équitable pour tous
et j'ai un plan pour ça et on doit créer
des emplois les opportunités pour nos
jeunes a pour nos travailleurs et c'est
ça sort est une priorité pour moi comme
chef de l'opposition parce que j'ai
travaillé pour une décennie dans le
secteur privé amah avant ma carrière
politique
d'accord mais est ce que pour arriver
un plus petit déficit ou un déficit zéro
vous allez devoir faire des compressions
où vous allez plutôt misé sur
l'augmentation de l'économie je vais
grossir notre économie notre pib
et ça serait mon approche et ont droit
et équilibrer le budget mais
probablement après une décennie dans ce
que l'on doit avoir un plan d'aidé les
entreprises et les travailleurs dans une
manière juste comme j'ai dit et c'est
pourquoi je vais parler avec mon caucus
la semaine prochaine pour commencer un
plan pour l'avenir de canada au kivu
disant ça va prendre au moins dix ans
donc pas de pas de remède de cheval pas
de compressions trop difficile à avaler
pour les canadiens non absolument non au
droit et des anneaux nos partenaires les
provinces incluant à le gouvernement
legault on doit travailler en étroite
collaboration sur sur l'économie sur la
santé nos aînés et je vais avoir un
plein aux as travaillé ensemble sur les
ch et celle des et les enjeux après la
pandémie
le gouvernement conservateur va être un
gouvernement sérieux et avec beaucoup
d'éthique c'est important d'avoir une
approche différente que monsieur to do
est ce que vous voulez a mené le parti
un peu plus au centre
on sait que le vote des conservateurs
sociaux vous ont aidé dans la mesure où
vous avez été le deuxième choix ou le
troisième choix pour eux mêmes selon
madame lewis & mrs londres on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait beaucoup de
militants conservateurs quand même
qu'ils provenaient de ce groupe des
conservateurs plus
religieux pelure conservateur plus
traditionnelle est ce que vous leur
devez quelque chose à ces gens là
j'étais élu comme une députée pro choix
j'ai un bilan clair sur les enjeux comme
l'avortement et le mariage gay a comme
un député un je vais défendre les droits
des canadiens comme chef de l'opposition
et comme féministe et je vais respecter
tous les canadiens et les autres points
de vue mais je vais défendre les doigts
comme communiste georges juste comme
j'ai fait dans armés en uniforme pour
défendre nos intérêts chez nous et à
travers le monde c'est important pour
moi personnellement mais vous avez dans
votre discours dans la nuit vous avez
parlé de tous les canadiens de toutes
les différences de toutes les religions
vous avez fait un appel aux francophones
québécois
donc est ce que vous voulez replacer le
parti conservateur un peu plus au centre
par rapport à où conservateurs qu'on
connaissait lors de la dernière campagne
lecteurs on doit parler sur les enjeux
importants pour les canadiens incluant
les québécois et québécoises et c'est
pourquoi je suis le seul candidat dans
la course à la chefferie avec une
plateforme politique spécifique pour le
québec ont droit grossir notre mouvement
on doit de gagner plus de sièges au
québec dans les prochaines élections
et moi je suis né au québec mais j'ai
grandi en ontario et comme chef
je vais gagner plus de sièges au québec
et en ontario dans la prochaine élection
c'est important pour moi personnellement
encore et j'ai une équipe extraordinaire
maintenant comme député et on doit
attirer les candidats y calida
extraordinaire ce retard est au québec
aussi très bien dernière question
surtout généreux laquelle on se reparle
et dernière question avez vous écouté
hier vous intéresser à la politique
américaine j'imagine le discours de mike
pence
comment vous comparez le mouvement
conservateur aux états unis et le
mouvement conservateur au canada c'est
totalement différent
ah parce que on a un pays
totalement défaillant et les enjeux
différents et je suis en politique pour
le bien-être des canadiens à travers le
pays et j'ai beaucoup d'expérience pour
ça et je vais je vais continuer sur
notre copain sur notre pays et par sur
les os j'avais que je dis nous dire
sereno tout nouveau chef du parti
conservateur merci à très bientôt on
aura l'occasion de se parler des enjeux
plus précisément au cours du prochain
mois
merci merci messieurs à voir